Let us start two days video with having
a look at a question.
If you could choose between living like
the richest and most powerful person in
the world,
save three or 400 years ago and say,
ah,
like George Washington or living today
as a normal middle class person from a
country like New Zealand,
Denmark,
or Canada,
well,
which one would you choose?
Well,
many of you watching right now might be
tempted to choose all of that power and
influence.
Right?
Well,
if you chose that option,
my dear friends,
I don't think you have thought it
through quite enough.
Okay.
Allow me to explain.
Choosing one of those historical super
fourteens would involve giving up basic
things like AC,
internet,
mobile phones,
movies,
pizza hands.
Well,
a whole other number of things that are
indispensable in our lives today.
Like pizza.
No,
no,
as of course,
then there's the fact that you'd have to
deal with a much,
much shorter life expectancy.
For example,
let's take a look at the description
that economists,
Xavier Salah,
El Martin made of Mansa Musa,
the first of Molly's life,
who at current prices would be
considered the richest person of all
time.
It took several months for a Mansa Musa
to travel the 5,000
kilometers that separate molly from
Mecca on horseback,
a trip that my modern plane,
I take about six and a half hours.
His palaces had no air conditioning,
no access to Google and his children can
play with a playstation or we
communicate with his colleague,
the Sultan on a series of Cairo,
Mansa,
Musa,
I know whatsapp,
facebook or mobile phone.
Of course,
he was never able to cure a headache
with an aspirin and I don't think that
100 years ago things were really much
better and that's fine.
John Rockefeller,
the well known oil magnates couldn't
even watch television and listen to the
radio or use antibiotic.
These luxury is simply did not exist.
Yes,
that is absolutely right.
If it is me making this decision on,
you know what I would choose,
I would absolutely choose a current
middle class life.
Indeed
I would avoid going back to the past as
much as I possibly could because saying
things were better back then simply
isn't.
Of course
all of this shouldn't really surprise
you either.
After all innovation,
technological development,
they've always been the main drivers for
improving people's quality of life
picture and sound coming together.
It's just like that.
Well,
regarding this,
I do have some good news for you and
also unfortunately I've got some bad
news.
The good news is the all evidence
suggests we are on the threshold of a
new era of revolutionary changes,
changes that only seems possible in
science,
novels,
previous
slate
and trucks that drive themselves.
Biotechnology,
robotics,
nano technology,
artificial intelligence for simply the
ability to share knowledge on a massive
scale through the clouds.
These are just a few of the huge changes
that are absolutely going to be coming.
The bad news is that several experts
state that both the speed and depth of
these changes have been slowing down for
decades.
This means,
but all of these technological miracles
could take a long time to arrive or
actually might never even arrive at all.
The big rake.
The last 20 years of the 19th century
and the first 50 of the 20th century for
something like a golden age of
innovation.
The changes that occurred in those few
decades was so great that even today
they seem like magic.
See,
many technologies were developed in
those times such as the automobile,
airplanes,
antibiotics,
electricity,
nuclear energy,
insecticides,
and many,
many,
many more things that really did change
people's lives forever.
With all of these changes in a little
more than 50 years,
humanity has stopped riding on horses
and found themselves able to travel to
the moon.
Things into perspective.
Let's have a look at the airplanes
evolution.
This went from being something like this
at the beginning of the 20th century to
something like this in the 50
[inaudible].
Okay,
let's take a look at how cars changed.
This is how they were at first and then
this is how they were in the 1950s no
mama.
Oh good.
Do you guys are gene?
We could
even mentioned the microwave.
It's technology that in a short time
went from being a theory to being used
in large rate panels and in virtually
every
kitchen.
The electricity.
We went from candles to light bulbs and
in a short amount of time communications
went from carrier pigeons to the First
Telegraph and the telephone.
It came soon after that.
In other words,
we are talking about eight spectacular
rates of technological developments
since then.
Let's just say that things they've
improved but not really so much
playing planes.
They are basically still the same.
Now they are safer and they are more
comfortable,
but it's still the same technology.
In fact,
we could say that the only field where
several disruptive innovations have
occurred has been in the digital world.
So now for you,
the only question we really need to
answer is,
well,
what actually happens?
Why are things going full steam in the
digital wells and not so much in the
other fields?
Well,
some people like Peter Teal have a clear
idea why I'm check this out.
We've had a lot of innovation in
computers,
information technology,
Internet,
mobile,
Internet in the world of bits,
not so much in the world of Adam's
supersonic travel space,
travel,
new forms of energy,
new forms of medicine,
new medical devices,
et cetera.
I would say that we lived in a world in
which bits were unregulated and Adams
were regulated.
Peter Teal.
All right,
sir,
said,
wait a minute.
Is Pizza deal saying that some bad
regulations are holding innovation back?
Well,
you know he's not actually the only one
who's saying this.
Many experts argue the innovation has
been facing what can be called an almost
a perfect storm for years.
This is a storm composed of,
among other things,
excessive regulations,
patterns and way too much
predict
post.
When we talk about holding innovation,
we need to know we are talking about
nothing all ask the whole thing
progress.
We are slowing down technologies that
could greatly improve our lives from
taking planes in space to the cure for
yeah,
cancer paralyzed by fear.
Yes,
so it is true.
Regulations do aim to improve safety and
the quality of life for citizens,
but intentions are one thing and
results.
That's something completely different.
Politicians often forget that
regulations also have negative
consequences and of course if there are
a lot of regulations,
consequences can be quite negative.
Let's take a look at,
for example,
what is happening in the pharmaceutical
research industry in the European Union,
which is of course a world leader in
Samsung regulations.
No,
how important medical and pharmaceutical
research is and how it can improve our
lives.
Well,
these huge regulations because the
development of new medicines to take
more than 10 years and we're not only
talking about the time it takes for
laboratories,
do comply with all the regulations here,
even after they finally obtained
authorization from the European
medicines agency,
if they still have to wait one more year
to launch their product into the market
simply because of bureaucracy.
Of course,
this all has pretty major consequences
for one,
they on greatly to lengthy innovative
process,
which is extensively based on past
experience for another.
They make research incredibly expensive.
We're talking about 10 or 12 years
investing a lot of money without the
chance of earning anything right
now.
Of course,
prudence and ensuring safety is
absolutely important,
but 10 to 12 years because of excessive
bureaucracy.
I mean maybe that playing it a bit too
safe here.
Okay.
And there's
another detail that we absolutely cannot
here.
The monopolization that in some way all
these regulations create for big
pharmaceutical multinationals.
Yes,
you heard that,
right.
Those who benefit the most from this
hyper regulation are precisely the large
pharmaceutical companies themselves.
Of course,
if small authorities can't cope with all
these costs in the market is changing
less because there's less innovation to
the large companies have a secure,
large and stable.
Yeah,
and the pharmaceutical industry,
this is just one example.
Let me reiterate here because I don't
want to be mistaken.
Regulations are absolutely important,
but we need to be very careful about
piper regulation because when we pile on
too many demands,
we increased prices and we hope the
progress that improves people's lives
the most,
which is of course
innovation.
Who gets it?
Who gets to write the regular
regulations?
The bureaucrats,
right?
The regulations,
but who writes the laws?
The lobbyists have controls,
so it's a lobbyists from the drug
industry has control of writing.
The regulations.
Example of the,
of all of this is mobile technology.
Did you know that this technology was
first developed in the 1940s yeah,
that's right.
Mobile communication,
it's really not as new as it seems and
the 1940s the mts mobile telephone
service began to be developed.
It was a standard.
They use radio waves to connect to a
landline with a mobile phone,
but of course now you may be wondering,
well,
why the hell did it take so long for
this technology to mature?
I mean,
at the end of the day,
the first modern mobile phones didn't
appear until the late eighties I didn't
become popular until the late nineties
well,
the answer to view at comes from
political class and regulations.
If we are to ignore the cost of
regulations,
if we are to ignore the relationship
between regulations and job loss,
there is basically no limit to the
fervor and ferocity that will be
unleashed by bureaucrats who's perpetual
mandate is to regulate.
See
the US federal communications commission
and managers by law and grants licenses
to the so-called radio spectrum.
This is how electromagnetic radio
frequencies are transmitted.
That is the signals that allow for
telecommunication.
Well,
when companies were investing in
developing mobile technology back in the
1950s the federal communications
commission,
which is after all a political body,
decided that all mobile phones
technology wasn't very important and
that the radio spectrum,
how to be used to boost another nascent
technology television.
The idea here that television was indeed
much more useful.
Totally.
I'm fantastical.
I'd met all know all the PV industry.
Now,
this is something that today we can
debate,
but the fact is that a large part of the
spectrum was assigned to television so
much more than was actually needed.
That means that those technologies could
have been developed at the same time,
but the regulator simply did not see a
future in mobile communications.
That's not it.
In in 1973 in motor read,
the Vice President Marty Cooper,
who is considered the father of mobile
phones to make the first call with one
of these devices that we all use today.
Yes,
you did not miss any of that date.
The first mobile phone call actually
happened way back in the 1970s but once
a game,
the regulator intervened and decided
that competition wasn't possible in
mobile telephones and assigns the entire
monopoly to a t.
And.
T.
Yes,
I think we can say that politicians and
regulators didn't hit the market tool
and ended up delaying the development of
mobile communications by more than 40
years.
All right,
so that was the case in the United
States,
but in Europe things they were also
going down a similar
entity
for you.
Think about it,
it's actually quite normal because
research and innovation are for
scientists and entrepreneurs and not for
politicians.
In fact,
this is the problem.
Many public r and D programs face who
cannot work because their work is
determined by politicians and by
bureaucrats are visual politic.
We've already discussed how governments
can play a prominent role in research
development and investing,
but need to do so while being aware of
their limitations.
This is actually what has happened in
Israel as we saw with,
he yells in my program,
which gave leadership to investors,
entrepreneurs and scientists who worked
in a competitive market.
If this isn't done,
programs and public aid can actually be
really counterproductive.
They can raise the costs of r and D and
I hinder startups progress and
ultimately holtz technological
developments and innovations,
which are the best ways,
as we've mentioned,
to improve everyone's quality of life.
All right,
well,
having settled with that,
now it's your turn.
Which countries do you think are going
to lead the future of the technological
race?
Please leave your answers in the
comments below as well as in this survey
ends.
I really do hope you enjoy this video.
Please do hit that like button if you
did and do not forget to subscribe to
our channel for brand new videos every
Monday and Thursday.
Call say,
don't forget to check it.
Our friends at the reconsider media
podcast,
they provided the vocals in this episode
that,
Oh,
not mine,
and as always,
thanks for watching.